pour la population générale des des 5 à
11 ans le comité d'orientation régionale
dirigée par alain fischer émis une
recommandation de vaccination chez ces
enfants à la fois à titre individuel et
collectif pour les raisons que je vous
indiquais les pédiatres sont pour le
moins mitigés sur cette indication
le conseil scientifique
voilà on va pas rajouter et la chaise
doit donner aussi un avis d'ici une
dizaine de jours le conseil scientifique
du pèse mes mots
si l'indication de vaccination chez
l'enfant est retenu soit qu'elle ne soit
pas obligatoire et qu'elle ne fasse pas
l'objet d'un pass sanitaire enfants
si une indication de vaccination est
retenu chez l'enfant
le conseil scientifique souhaite qu'elle
ne soit pas obligatoire et qu'il n'y ait
pas d'indication impasse sanitaires chez
l'enfant
ensuite voyons les choses en face des
familles et autour de vous peut-être
chez vos enfants
certains vont aller pour dix ans mais si
je vais faire vacciner mes enfants et
d'autres au contraire de novembre
si on regarde le plan international on
en est les etats unis ont démarré depuis
trois semaines et d'ailleurs le groupe
d'alain fischer avec grande justesse
réclame d'attendre un peu con et les
premières données de toxicité éventuelle
ou d'effets secondaires qui pourraient
être observées chez les enfants aux
états unis mais j'ai un petit fiscalité
vacciner là bas
et deuxièmement en europe c'est mitigé
les italiens bons vacciner les
israéliens en vacciner les allemands
sont en train d'aller à la vaccination
bien d'autres pays où les autrichiens
mais l'angleterre par exemple non
l'espagne n'ont donc loyer qu'il ya
encore une illusion
[Musique]